all right
okay here we go
some bullet an hour of bullet
the eastern bullet arena
i let them get that in about this though
get a pawn i'm their bishop
on that guy
get this guy
let's just stay right here
why can i not take this
this pawn going around their queen
should be good
i shouldn't have given up that pawn
okay had enough time in the tank there
uh matt o'brien no i'm not familiar
seeing a question in the chat
let's try some e4 stuff
e4 stuff
long neck the opponent
tough time now i think for that bishop
he's got to move again before the queen
side could be developed
stuck this exchange
can take
and really fast
bishop there
not afraid of their knight he's under
control
okay
wow jeez
slow down man
this guy has the pedal to the metal
constantly throwing jabs at me
oh i'm down on time
holy cow that guy i felt like i was on
my heels the whole game that guy was
throwing threats left and right
i couldn't
i couldn't uh i don't know
i was kind i was in a constant state of
just react
all right let's let's slow down here
okay okay okay
ah man i want that game
i want that one back
they're in the tank
why did i take that pawn nobody knows
a time edge where was that last game
okay back to tournament
whoo okay
184 in there
fast chances in first sincerity is right
there sincerity is
so fast
so fast
why don't i take that knight
what's going on
let's keep it solid
i want to queenside castles
oh boy
don't hurt me on the dark squares please
oh they were just setting that up
bishop f4
okay
turn the tank
put a knight on d5
no time
okay i got a six i'm fishing for a four
my first four andrew streaming
mad quick
andrew is mad quick
god daniel x
good player
they moved i didn't realize
jump into f4 gonna hurt me
where's the night going it's getting
cornered
uh oh queen and knight are hanging
problemos let's open up my bishop's eyes
keep the file look for mates
got the mates all right
let's go we're barely in there
top 10 in 10th place just knocked out of
10th
sicilian i got to watch with that a6
because sometimes they sneak in bishop
g5 i've
felt that pain before not fun
unopposed center we're gonna go queen
side
look for some quick punches on b2 maybe
all right let's just secure the
this side of the board is all be sneaky
whoa what's that
block with the bishop
queen takes then there was a follow-up
knight there whoa
is that
looking a little scary
oh that would have hurt me really bad
really really bad
queen b4 with that knight right there
i'm up a pawn but it's scary
okay i could get the queens off let's
roll pawns
get out get to push
i don't want to push though let's get
this square
they're a long way out from creating a
passer
sneaky sneaky sneaky all right they
resigned
let us see
where i'm at seventh let's try e4
ah all right
we're gonna have to try and make a game
bit out of it how do you do that though
yuck
all right triple pawns take him
i don't want him all right doubled pawns
doubled and isolated
check take the knight and take the
bishop if they castle
there's no rookie eight
sneaky
in between or city they don't want that
afraid of knight g5 they're really
underdeveloped
oh i have a queen check to win their
bishop if they take my bishop
let's look at those unprotected pieces
maybe i'd throw this in first just for
fun
threaten mate threat mate again queen h4
after g6
and we'll take
no time okay
fast chance is off to a blazing start 28
with fires in a game
ferrari's in second with a speed bump
247 in there
let's see okay this is the number number
three guy
i'm playing as white let's get a move on
let's get this in
my blender
dead eye blunder
let's kick that knife back let's get
back here
whoa whoa whoa it's almost
really bad
oh they had my bishop there
okay let's go here
um
let's get a passer
what am i doing what am i doing
oh
i could take my rook
oh man they were flying
their queen was just way too active
did i let them race their rook pawn down
like that my rook move was ridiculous
setting up some c form with the
discovery against their queen big deal
what does that really accomplish
nobody knows
okay
i'm already in trouble with this one
setting up a sacrifice there
give up a pawn just to get a square
and something over here on the queen
side
of a passer
is that a is that a rook
he takes pawn was a move
nice
take my queen i take their queen
i'm on the rook
my knight's a monster
oh so hard
whoo a lot of pressure on my king side
there
ah there he is mad
quick andrew's gonna throw c5 at me
nope
um centralize let's get c4 in
gotta go fast we know he's gonna go fast
94 94.
got forks one day
there's the fork got the forks
how can we keep things simple can we get
the queens off
get the flight square first let's run
pawn
get out of there i do not want to see
you
watching over g2
keep it open i don't want to see a5
no rook b8
let's get these these rooks rolling
rig b8
on their back foot down on the clock
rook c8 next stay off of b1
all right there he's done good game
andrew
mad quick that was the first loss he was
on a streak
don't let me do that to you okay
ferrari's in first big surprise
he just finished no game against the
ferrari
all right
give me the h file
got the h file
i don't want to castle just yet i'll
take a pawn
get the structure queen b4
it's castle now before it's too late
take with the pawn i like g2 for my king
super duper cozy
on c7 trade queens
could also capture it on c7
get some pigs
nice and easy
improve the king
straighten out my pawns
improve the king
ready to push push
get the rook in a couple oh no oh
man mouse slip
oh oh man oh man
careful
oh my rook h6
nice got some nm's ims and the fm's
a lot of time to go 37 and change
okay
let's break it open better developed
side
fork
got the forks
the exchange that's silly
um let's go here play in the center
all right put some pawns on light
squares
if we can control those nights all this
night's dead
that's why they're not moving didn't
realize
back to tournament 30 still 11 back 4140
37 sincerity rules uh
super duper fast
really fast
get the queens off
can we get the queens up
not that
just losing a pawn no
i got this pawn back
i think so
they're tricks there's tricks
90 okay
my rooks are looking kind of weird
kind of weird
my knight on c5 i like
wow
[Music]
takes my breath away man
andrew again team white
queen b6
no queen b6 c4 bishop f5
yes
put my bishop on c2
we're getting in a break on the queen
side
being sneaky it's poison
something here
being sneaky two minor pieces for the
rook
keep this knight around queen on f5
do something that looks active rook
takes bishop is maybe in the air
let's go for that
all right good game andrew
32 and change
ferrari is still in first
38 i'm nearby
nearby i i expect i will be getting
paired at least in the second half of
the tournament
with those pack leaders
let's go queenside
let's go here bishop on c4 now
knight here why am i allowing knight
there
tuck my king away whose king is safer i
don't know
centralize uh oh
it's it open
um here
what does that even do
wow wow
i have back rank issues
careful
there might be back rank problemos
there it is
that pawn is pretty serious right here
split the uprights there mate
okay 47 45 43
42 it's a battle
love it all right mad quick again andrew
okay playing as black this time
let's go with the french
the exchange french
let's keep that pin if we can
i'll get the light square bishop off
get this moving threatening f7 there
i'm the bishop oh
they had that defended enough
let's get centralized
okay my knights better than theirs
on f4
i want to get here why am i trading off
i want to go there
where am i going there
oh my goodness
whoa i mouse slipped there at the end
too
good game andrew ah the ferrari
um what do we play against the ferrari i
guess e5
am i asking for trouble probably
some dark squares to maybe work with
it's an unusual position
trying to undermine my king side very
sensible
why am i doing that
oh i have this move
i'm in trouble though
i have night here
ah tough tough tough
i can't move
that was helpful
bye
so fast the ferrari always
puts the pressure on uh thank you for
the
anonymous gift sub
there were some anonymous
gifted a sub thank you
i should have played e6
okay why am i doing that
going all in on the king side
swiping that guy
to try and make some magic happen over
here
my bishop controls the c pawn
okay that got really wild
they were going on the queen side i was
trying to do something on the king side
a point out of first i love that e5
square
that's a whole
let's jump in let's have some fun on e5
i'm not done yet oh
i don't want that exchange
let's try it again
i don't mind it now take like this play
against this guy if i can they're trying
to exchange them off
now we make some progress on the queen
side
make sure d4 is covered put pressure
here
queen e3 clean here
look for a6
could have captured here down on time
okay i have a one point lead
barely barely barely
barely a lead
knight on f5 is very good especially
when the light square bishops are
gonzo
let's get the oh sacrifice here
okay here's the plan this
and put the knight on g6
hang on they're going to undermine c4
soon
do not castle whatever you do do not
castle king side
i need some defense there
well the queen isn't around anymore
um queen there would be a mistake
how am i making progress
um maybe my king needs
i kind of lucked out with that
they took the bait but it wasn't even it
was not intended bait
that's the thing
stay here
stop this push
now get that pawn already would you
activate my queen
get the queen if the rook gets no there
can't get there but i have checks on the
back rank rook h1 stuff
all my time
there it is time though
well i was going to get the rook soon
but my time
back three long neck this is the guy
that got me
it's constantly throwing threats at me
throwing threats
okay
what am i doing they can't even capture
that
oh man oh man what's my knight doing
the control theirs control their night
ah i got your queen okay they resigned
[Laughter]
they're in pre-move mode 69 66
61 still back three this guy's having a
really good run
only one loss jagaram
take with the pawn get some space
stop bishop f5 i thought
stop bishop f5 is that not a tough pawn
to
hold on to
digging with the pawn was probably
pretty good too
give a check
let's get rid of their night soon
think i win a pawn no
where's
i get rook b6 i'm up upon and i maintain
activity
take there and back over
um it's not me
okay everything is covered
whoo that guy keeps winning we're both
on
pretty good streaks
73 70 65.
14 to go a long neck again
[Music]
it's the cairo
all right prepare to give that up
all right trying to play against the
structure don't allow that pawn to
undouble
clamp down the queen side
and jump around with the knight
this guy should be going after
um okay
let's make some progress
like wow
okay
and upon
another one
oh get to take their bishop and then
take their rook they're so fast
kustav is flying too i think we're
getting a pairing yeah
it's the number one dog
see if i could get some space
give me the dark square bishop
let's get out of any pins
big square to control
okay they're getting a square
i'm getting a square
um here
bishop here i should be going for try to
kick that knight away
i don't want to give up my dark square
bishop though
like the two bishops
go for that and bishop here
um stop queen h3 in case they capture
oh we both mouth slipped
yes discover check i get the queen all
right promote to a queen whew that was a
big win 11 to go
we both mouse slipped well no i didn't
mouth slip i blundered
my opponent mouse slipped with g4
i could have captured on g4
okay
put some pressure on b5 target c5
c6
i could stop that advance that'd be nice
okay i get to stop at night here we
trade nights
they're getting ready they're no they're
having a tough
tough time now i think
to go here not fun
uh yeah let's get this file
bishop takes pawn
push
i could just grab that pawn here and
then here
let's check here and then i get
here
why'd i take that one
i just look out there i did
now they're sealed i get this next
oh stalemates let's keep allow them to
keep a move we got me
okay and first by a point
eight in change thank you beckoning ryan
for the tier one sub
just seeing that now
okay back i go
the f5 square don't want to see that
ah i just gave up g5
all right um
oh i have this pawn my center is ripped
to shreds
yuck oh i'm in a pin now
can't get out of it i'm in trouble
big trouble
queens are coming off soon
um that's looking good
a lot of ways to do it
yeah threatening me okay
um it's a big loss i'm back too now
ferrari's right there as well
huh photo finish ferrari probably has
the edge
he's in a game he's got fire
three games maybe four go
four to go
threatening a fork
control that f5 square
and keep a grip over here
full rook
here get the queens off next
queen c2 they resigned
okay 84 ferrari slipped up
kustov is back on fire and up two five
and change
hmm
okay uh this is the guy that got me last
time
okay
why'd i go there
letting them have too easy a time
far too easy a time
queen h4
okay
my bishop's holding things together
their king is way too active though
is he close to mated i don't want to
give up the c file
i'm back four he's in a game if he wins
tie breaks 25 i have i could maybe win
on tie breaks he'd have to lose
bengulio
build my center
okay hang on to that i don't want to put
my queen
right here
i like seeing that move
get that b3 square
it's the new seventh rank
let's get this guy
okay they resigned i'm still back for
20 25 99 performance where's he at
in a game he's in a game if he wins he's
got it
ferrari
looking at f4 let's go with this
sneaky guy very sneaky guy
that's not going to finish
god i'm about way too far away
no buzzer beater chances okay
502 in there
good games all man it's been a while
since i played in the eastern build
arena while streaming
there's your page one
page two
tight tight race all right
very very nice fun as usual
you